What would you say to a BO if they ask,
can you teach me to build my own website?
Or this one's probably one that people get more often
is why do I need you when I can build my own website?
Seems easy enough.
And I guess my clarification,
and I'm gonna make some assumptions here,
but my clarification is like,
are we building websites or are we generating leads?
So I'm assuming that you're talking about generating leads.
And if the business owner,
if that's just wasn't clarified, then that's fine.
But let's say the business owner said,
why do I need you if I can just build my own website
and get my own leads?
Then my question or my response to that would be like,
if you honestly, sir, if you can do that,
then you should go do that by all means, by all means.
But like, why haven't you done that yet?
Right?
Like that makes zero sense.
Like, and so I don't think I've ever got the second one.
Why would like, why do I need you?
Then I guess my question would be like,
well, then why are you paying home advisor?
If you could do it, why haven't you done it yet?
Right.
And I'm not gonna,
I know that like a lot of people want me to go,
probably say, well, you should focus on your business
and I'll focus on mine.
It's like, no, call them out.
Okay, Bob, go do it.
And guess, I'd probably kind of be a little bit,
I'd probably be a little tongue in cheek here
and I'd go, I'd say something like along the lines of like,
oh, I didn't know you had that skillset.
If you have that skillset,
like I'm looking for good people.
Why don't you just build the website
and then I'll buy the leads from you?
No, seriously, because I think I can go get,
sell them somewhere else for hire.
Like, and honestly, if you know how to build them,
then do it A for yourself and then we should talk
because maybe you can help me with some of these webs.
Like they're full of crap, okay?
That's number one.
The first part of it, which was,
what was the first part of that question?
Which was, what was it?
Can you teach me to build my own website?
Is that what you're referring to?
Oh, yeah.
If they ask that, I would just say, yeah, I can.
But like, are you, you just want a website?
Again, is it, can you,
can you teach me to build my own website
or can you teach me to get leads?
Because there's a big difference
between getting leads and building a website.
Because if you just want to build a website,
then why don't you just go to GoDaddy
and throw up a website.
But guess what?
A website for a website's sake is a waste of money.
If your website's not generating leads,
why do you have a website?
Yeah.
Yeah, and the only other thing I'd add to that is,
one, they're probably not qualified.
So it's probably a business owner
that you would want to work with in the first place.
But then it also just goes back to the monopoly model
that we talked about.
Like, hey, the whole goal is to get your property,
our property, and you get as many leads as possible.
But if you don't want more leads,
then you can just stick with your website.
So. 100%.
100%.